>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
MY BLOCK, MY HOOD, MY CITY IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN
CHICAGO.
IT'S DESIGNED TO TEACH KIDS HOW
TO BECOME RESPONSIBLE CITIZENS.
WE CAN'T TELL YOU IF THE PROGRAM
ACTUALLY WORKS BUT WE DO SEEM TO
BE AIMING IN THE RIGHTS
DIRECTION.
LAST SATURDAY AFTERNOON FOUR
MEMBERS OF THIS GROUP WENT TO
CHICAGO'S TO HANG CHRISTMAS
LIGHTS.
PRETTY NICE THING TO DO.
ONCE THE CENTER OF CHICAGO'S
BLACK OWNED BUSINESS DISTRICT AT
THIS POINT ANOTHER DANGEROUS
NEIGHBORHOOD IN A DECAYING CITY.
HOW DANGEROUS IS IT?
WELL, IF THE KIDS HUNG THEIR
CHRISTMAS LIGHTS FOUR THUGS GOT
OUT OF AN SUV AND ROBBED THEM.
THEN A FEW HOURS LATER SOMEONE
SET FIRE TO A CHRISTMAS DEGREE
THEY HAD SET UP IN A NEARBY
PARK.
WHO SETS FIRE TO CHRISTMAS
TREES?
WELL, SUDDENLY A LOT OF DO.
LAST DECEMBER THE SAME GROUP OF
VOLUNTEERS IN CHICAGO HAD
ANOTHER ONE OF THEIR CHRISTMAS
TREES BURNED DOT GROUND.
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT, SOMEONE
RAN OVER THE CHRISTMAS TREE IN
CHICAGO'S WASHINGTON PARK WITH A
CAR.
TO THERE SEEMS TO BE QUITE A BIT
OF CHRISTMAS TREE DESTROYING
GOING ON ALL OF THE SUDDEN.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
WALL, WELL, LET'S SEE.
THIS ISN'T JUST A MATTER OF
PEOPLE SETTING FIRE TO BALSAM
FIRS, A CHRISTMAS TREE IS A
SYMBOL.
A SYMBOL OF A SPECIFIC CULTURE.
A SYMBOL OF A MUCH LOVED
TRADITION HUNDREDS OF YEARS OLD.
ABOVE ALL, IT'S A SYMBOL OF A
RELIGION, IN THIS CASE THE
WORLD'S LARGEST RELIGION.
TORCHING CHRISTMAS TREES IS AN
ATTACK ON CHRISTIANITY.
OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S AN ASSAULT ON RELIGIOUS
OBSERVANCE.
BY CURRENT STANDARDS, DESTROYING
SOMEONE'S RELIGIOUS SYMBOL WOULD
BE CALLED A HATE CRIME.
THAT'S A CATEGORY MUCH BELOVED
AND METICULOUSLY CHRONICLED BY
THE BIDEN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THE DOJ CAN TELL YOU PRECISELY
HOW MANY YOUR RANS WERE BURNED
LAST YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
BUT THEY DON'T KEEP TRACK OF
CHRISTMAS TREES.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL, BECAUSE THEY COULD CARE
LESS.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY ISN'T
DISPATCHING A TEAM OF FBI AGENTS
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
CHRISTMAS ARSON.
MERRICK GARLAND IS NOT GOING TO
ISSUE A PRESS RELEASE ABOUT IT.
TRUST US.
THE MEDIA FOR THEIR PART FIND
THE WHOLE THING HILARIOUS.
AFTER A CHRISTMAS DISPLAY WAS
VANDALIZED THREE YEARS IN A ROW
IN A PARK IN CHICAGO, MOST
RECENTLY THIS PAST WEEKEND, CBS
NEWS PRODUCED THIS HEADLINE,
QUOTE:  SEARCH ON FOR GRINCH WHO
BURNED DOWN CHRISTMAS TREE.
OH, SO IT'S A GRINCH.
NOT AN ARSONIST?
NOT DANGEROUS ANTI-CHRISTIAN
PSYCHO PATH, GRINCH, AMUSING
CUTE CARTOON CHARACTER NOBODY
CAN TAKE SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
THESE ARE NOT ISOLATED
INCIDENTS.
AND THEY ARE NOT BEING
PERPETRATED BY GRINCHES.
IN OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA A FEW
DAYS AGO, STILL UNIDENTIFIED
ARSONIST DOUSED A 52-FOOT
CHRISTMAS TREE WITH LIGHTER
FLUID AND BURNED IT DOWN.
JUST THIS MORNING RIGHT AFTER
MIDNIGHT IN THE CENTER OF
MIDTOWN MANHATTAN SOMEONE
TORCHED THE CHRISTMAS TREE RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF FOX NEWS
HEADQUARTERS.
IT WENT UP IN SMOKE WHILE
SALESMAN NONE BREAM WAS LIVE ON
THE AIR.
>> ALL RIGHT A BIT OF BREAKING
NEWS FOR YOU DON'T.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT LIVE IMAGES
THIS IS THE FOX SQUARE IN NEW
YORK OUTSIDE OF FOX
HEADQUARTERS.
IT APPEARS THAT OUR GIANT
CHRISTMAS TREE THERE JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES AGO CASS
COMPLETELY ENGULFED IN FLAMES IT
APPEARS CREWS ARE THERE ON THE
SCENE, YOU SEE THE SMOKE AND
AFTERMATH AS THEY ARE TRYING TO
GET THAT UNDER CONTROL.
>> Tucker: IN THIS CASE THE TREE
IN FRONT OF FOX NEWS MANHATTAN
POLICE CAUGHT THE MAN WHO DID
HIS NAME IS CRAIG HE HAD A
LIGHTER IN HIS POCKET.
SECURITY SAW HIM LIGHT THE FIRE.
WHY DID HE DO THIS?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE MORE OBVIOUS QUESTION IS WHY
WAS HE ON THE STREET IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
ACCORDING TO NEW YORK'S POLICE
COMMISSIONER HE WAS WANTED ON
SEVERAL CRIMINAL OFFENSES.
QUOTE, HE WAS ISHTEDZ EARLIER
THIS YEAR SOME APPEARANCE
TICKETS AND DIDN'T COME BACK TO
COURT, WHICH IS SOMETHING WE SEE
ALL TOO OFTEN.
SO HERE WE HAVE YET ANOTHER
CRIMINAL SET FREE BY LEFT WING
IDEALOGUES TO TERRORIZE EVERYONE
ELSE.
THIS IS THE THIRD ARSON ATTACK
ON A CHRISTMAS TREE AT LEAST IN
A MAJOR AMERICAN CITY IN THE
PAST WEEK.
TIME TO CONNECT SOME DOTS HERE?
NO.
HERE'S THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
HEADLINE, QUOTE:  FOX NEWS
CHRISTMAS TREE CATCHES FIRE IN
MANHATTAN.
RIGHT, SO IT TURNS OUT THE TREE
JUST CAUGHT FIRE.
IT SELF-EMULATED THE USUAL
SPONTANEOUS COMBUSTION LIKE THAT
RED SUV THAT WENT ROGUE AFTER
THE WRINS VERDICT IN WISCONSIN
AND BY ITSELF MURDERED CHILDREN
AND GRANDMOTHERS IN A PARADE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THESE THINGS
JUST HAPPEN.
IT WAS NOT LONG AGO THAT YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" WAS A SIMI WILL HE YET
MAT NEWSPAPER THAT REPORTED THE
NEWS.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS A STALINIST
PROPAGANDA OUTLET DESIGNED TO
CONFIRM THE BIGOTRIES OF THE
SMALLEST BEHINDED UNHAPPINESS
MOST UNSATISFIED PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT WASN'T ALWAYS
NPR.
BUT NOW IT IS.
AND VERY FEW PEOPLE ARE STILL
LISTENING.
EVERYONE WHO ACTUALLY LIVES IN
THIS COUNTRY KNOWS EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON, LOOK AROUND.
OUR STREETS ARE DANGEROUS.
MUCH MORE DANGEROUS THAN THEY
HAVE BEEN IN A LONG TIME, IN
DECADES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS FOR
THAT.
BUT ONE REASON IS OUR CITIES ARE
OVERRUN WITH MENTALLY UNSTABLE
VAGUE GRANTS LIVING ON THE
SIDEWALK.
NOW, FOR A LONG TIME WE HAVE
CALLED PLEASE PEOPLE HOMELESS.
LET'S STOP DOING THAT.
THE HOMELESS IS A POLITICAL TERM
WHICH IS INTENTIONALLY DEVISED
TO MISLEAD YOU.
IN FACT, THIS PROBLEM HAS VERY
LITTLE TO DO WITH HOMES OR
AVAILABLE HOUSING.
OR WHATEVER ORWELLIAN PHRASE
THEY ARE USING AT THIS POINT TO
PRETEND THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO
PLACE TO STAY.
A LOT OF THEM COULD BE STAYING
INDOORS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE THEY
ARE ADDICTED TO DRUGS.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
AMERICA HAS A MASSIVE DRUG
CRISIS NOW IN PROGRESS.
THE REST OF US HAVE BEEN TRAINED
TO IGNORE IT OR DENY IT.
BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY REAL.
AND IF YOU LIVE IN THE CITY, YOU
CANNOT PRETEND IT ISN'T.
YANG RAN BE FOR MAYOR OF NEW
YORK THIS SPRING AND ONE POINT
MADE THE MISTAKE OF SAYING WHAT
EVERYONE IN MANHATTAN KNOWS IS
TRUE.
>> THE FACT IS MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS MEN ARE CHANGING THE
CHARACTER OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
A WOMAN, MY WIFE ELLEN IS
FRIENDS WITH IN HER MOM'S GROUP
HELL'S KITCHEN PUNCHED IN THE
FACE.
THIS IS HAPPENING NEW YORK CITY
AND NOT TALKING ENOUGH ABOUT IT
FAMILIES ARE LEAVING AS A RESULT
AND EAST HARLEM THE NEIGHBORHOOD
HAS BEEN CHANGED, UPPER WEST
SIDE THE NEIGHBORHOOD HAS BEEN
CHANGED.
WE OWE OUR PEOPLE AND OUR
FAMILIES BETTER THAN THIS AND
I'M FRUSTRATED BY THE POLITICAL
NATURE OF THESE RESPONSES.
I MEAN, WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
HOUSINGS AFFORDABILITY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
HUNDREDS OF MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
WE ALL SEE AROUND US EVERY DAY
IN THE SUBWAYS THERE WOULD BE NO
RECOVERY UNTIL WE RESOLVE THIS I
WILL FIX THIS, NEW YORK.
>> Tucker: SO HERE YOU HAVE AN
INNOCENT MOTHER PUNCHED IN THE
FACE ON THE STREET.
NOW YOU WOULD THINK THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN CAUCUS MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THIS?
BUT, NO, INSTEAD THEY ATTACKED
ANDREW YANG FOR NOTING IT ANDREW
YANG'S COMMENTS ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS ARE DEEPLY OFFENSIVE
BARKED TEEN VOGUE WHICH IS EVEN
STUPIDER VERSION OF THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE MILLIE
DENOUNCED YANG AS DEEPLY
DISTURBING, DEEPLY LACKING IN
COMPASSION.
NOT MENTIONING THE WOMAN WHO GOT
PUNCHED IN THE FACE BY THE
LUNATIC.
NO COMPASSION FOR HER.
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN DON'T
COUNT WHEN IT'S HOMELESS
COMMITTING IT IN THE END ANDREW
YANG LOST THE MAYOR'S RACE.
THE MENTALLY ILL DRUG ADDICTS
WHO PUNCHED THE WOMAN IN THE
FACE IS STILL THERE AND ROAMING
MIDTOWN PROTECTED CLASS.
THEY MUST BE REFERRED TO AS
UNHOUSED INDIVIDUALS OR WHO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY HAVE A
TRITE LIVE IN TENTS ACROSS FROM
YOUR HOUSE SHOOTING HEROIN WITH
THEIR PANTS DOWN AS YOU WALK
YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL.
THEY REALLY THINK THAT WHEN THE
CITY OF WASHINGTON, D.C. MOVED
AN ENCAMPMENT OF EXPWRUNKIES
RECENTLY ONE CITY COUNCILMAN
DESCRIBED THIS AS QUOTE AN
EVICTION.
IN OTHER WORDS YOUR STREEFTS
BELONG TO THEM.
NOW, THESE AREN'T JUST MISGUIDED
ATTITUDES.
THEY ARE SUICIDAL ATTITUDES.
ANY SOCIETY THAT GIVES DRUG
ADDICTS PREFERENCE OVER HOME
OWNERS WILL NOT LAST LONG.
IN THE MEANTIME, PEOPLE DIE.
PEOPLE DIE AND DON'T DESERVE TO
DIE.
IN FLORIDA THE OTHER DAY A I
HAVE A GRANT MURDERED 1-YEAR-OLD
BOY OUT RIDING HIS BIKE.
POLICE SAY THE KILLER IS CALLED
WILLIAMS HE HAD FELONY ARRESTS
IN GEORGIA AND CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING CHARGES FOR AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT AND BATTERY.
WHY WASN'T HE IN JAIL?
AUTHORITIES IN GEORGIA AND
CALIFORNIA LET HIM GO.
SO HE WENT TO FLORIDA AND
MURDERED A CHILD.
>> HE APPEARS TO BE A HOMELESS
DRIFTER SPENDING MOST OF HIS
TIME IN THE STREETS OF MIAMI.
THE INCIDENT ITSELF APPEARS TO
BE A COMPLETELY RANDOM ACT WE DO
NOT HAVE A MOTIVE IN THIS CASE.
IT APPEARS TO BE AN ABSOLUTE
CHANCE ENCOUNTER BETWEEN A CHILD
ON A BICYCLE AND AN ANIMAL THAT
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BE OUT ON
OUR STREETS.
TUCK APPEARS TO BE RANDOM ACT.
DO YOU WONDER ABOUT THAT.
BUT HE CALLED HIM AN ANIMAL THAT
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BE OUT ON
OUR STREETS.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
SAYING THAT OUT LOUD WILL NOT
RETURN THIS BOY TO HIS PARENTS.
HE IS DEAD.
SAYING IT OUT LOUD IS A START.
YOU CANNOT SOLVE PROBLEMS UNTIL
YOU RESOLVE